[Music]
[Applause]
he's uh one of the popular co-hosts of
NFL Network's good morning football Kyle
Brandt joining us on the program he's uh
a torn Achilles Survivor
um I don't know how big that Community
is how often they meet but uh Kyle joins
us on the program you're on the
sidelines last night at MetLife Jet Life
Stadium that's right how would you
describe the atmosphere
it's the sharpest fastest 180 I've ever
seen in in about 20 seconds
Rogers is running out with an American
flag on 9 11. it's the people who have
covered the Jets for 30 years say it's
the loudest they've ever heard the
stadium and then 20 seconds later he's
on the cart I'm standing on this on the
field Dan and I'm standing next to some
First Responders who are being honored
there the New York firefighters the
second he goes down I'm standing next to
him the guy turns to me and he says oh
he's done he's done and I go really he
goes he's done
um the weirdest thing about last night I
don't think this came off on the
broadcast is that there was really
bizarre weather in New Jersey last night
there was a shelter in place warning
there was all sorts of rain and stuff so
thousands of jets fans were late
arriving to the stadium I had to leave
right after the injury because I had to
do the morning television then I walk
out of MetLife and the first thing I saw
with these Jets fans coming in there was
a family of five it was a husband it was
a wife it was three kids one of the kids
was on the dad's shoulders all five of
them are wearing number eight Aaron
Rodgers jerseys they don't know what
happens they walk into the stadium with
thousands of other Jets fans and they're
like what the hell is Wilson doing in
the game it was genuinely sad I felt bad
for him I have no bad jokes I think it
was a terrible thing yeah I'm Sports
depressed today you know that I don't
know if there's a clinical condition for
that but it's just you don't want to see
we wanted to see what the possibility
was for the Jets and and I I mentioned
this to the audience the highest of
highs and lowest of lows you know would
you put the Falcons leading 28-3 in the
Super Bowl to losing this like I'm
trying to look at comps for this Bill
Buckner and the Red Sox are going to win
the World Series ball goes through his
legs
um Bartman with the Cubs like the
highest of highs in the lowest of lows
and I don't know if you have one that
comes to mind well Bartman was really
personal to me I'm from Chicago but I
remember that you know that three hours
of that game six before it all fell
apart I said we're going to the World
Series we had the joy it was taken from
us but the Falcons fans had a great day
that day until the second half turned
around against the Patriots because the
worst part is Dan if the Jets fan thing
happens last night they didn't even get
a completed pass they didn't even get a
taste and then they got to wake up in
this morning and be insulted by seeing
names like Carson Wentz and Taylor
heinecke that doesn't help that's not
what
uh Rogers demeanor and you of course
tore your Achilles I did but Rogers I
think and Kobe when Kobe tore his I you
from what I'm told and you'll know it
better but they knew it like Rogers knew
that this was something serious Kobe
knew it was something and it was
something different because it's not a
knee it's not an ankle it's an Achilles
what is that feeling like when you first
know some I just did something really
stupid it's distinct it's not I turned
my ankle those guys do that three times
a night it's not someone stepped on me
I'm just gonna walk it off give me a
second you know immediately that
something's broken I ruptured my
achilles at the exact same age as Aaron
Rodgers 39 years old it was the same
legs the same injury I'm not liking my
myself to him as an athlete but we're
both flesh and blood and the thing they
never want to do is they never want to
go down you notice that both Rogers and
Kobe they get up and try to walk it off
and then they go down and when I was
reading about last night one of the
linemen from the Jets goes down to help
up the quarterback and he says no I'm
not getting up it's a sickening
certainty that your body is not hurt
it's broken and there's something
missing and that's why you know Dan this
morning I I detest this phrase that's
going around right now about they fear
he has a ruptured Achilles let me make
this very clear the Achilles test for a
rupture it is five seconds long you do
it on the field you put the athlete on
their stomach or on the table you
squeeze their calf if their foot moves
the Achilles intact if it doesn't move
it's ruptured so any team that fears the
Achilles is torn it's done they know
already there's no fear it's a certainty
yeah I so it's a this is probably a
formality I don't know why it is but
he's going to do a you know MRI this
morning and they're going to find out
that it is a torn Achilles but the
recovery part of this at that age you're
just coming back to have normalcy in
your life he's trying to come back to
play quarterback in the NFL uh handicap
you know what it's going to take
well you make the point I was trying to
be able to take out the garbage again
and carry in groceries Rogers is going
to try to lead the Jets again I think
he'll have surgery within the week you
do it as fast as possible and then you
rehab you rehab you rehabs and listen if
he wants to play football and the Jets
want him to he'll be ready to throw the
football in the spring and then I expect
that he will I said it this morning I'll
say it again I don't think this is over
one it's possible medically he's older
fine we saw Dan Marino tear his Achilles
come back and throw for 4 000 yards the
next season but also looks Aaron Rodgers
is not only the most talented
quarterback I've ever seen he's by far
the pettiest and by far one of the most
ego driven there is no way he's gonna
let the story end being crumpled up on a
cart on September 11th in New Jersey I
think he will be back he's under
contract he's not going to be pushed out
by some sort of Jordan love figure he
was the farv I think a rehab like crazy
throw in the spring and be ready to play
in the fall I don't think he'll let it
end like this he's a torn Achilles
Survivor uh thoughts and prayers Kyle
Brandt from Good Morning football
joining us on the program
what would you do if you ran the Jets
um I would look put on the tape of the
defense and a breeze Hall and I would
sit there and do nothing and I'd say
Zach Wilson sit down son you're gonna
practice your handoffs and you're gonna
throw it away and we're gonna punt the
bejesus out of this season and we're
gonna Trent Dill for this thing and
we're gonna try to get to the playoffs
I've seen all the names I mentioned
already Carson Wentz and Heineken listen
Schrager was stirring the pot this
morning trying to say that Brady is
gonna join the Jets which would be 10
times Jeter decided to become a Red Sox
at the end of his career because he
offered some ownership I don't see it I
know Brady's here I also know Brady
looks to be about 140 pounds happy and
at rest for the first time in his life
you want to set him up behind that jet
Soul line but these Jets fans who have
hated him and now are gonna celebrate it
I would sit there and be like Zach
Wilson don't kill the season for us the
Brady thing's fascinating but then if
they offered to make him a trillionaire
at the end of life I think maybe you can
get his interest a trillionaire though
well I think that's what people have to
realize that offensive line is not
getting better you can get better at the
quarterbacking position by bringing in
Tom Brady but the line doesn't get any
better and Brady is slower less athletic
than Aaron Rodgers is and if I'm Tom
Brady I I would say can you send me all
of the offensive lineman play from this
year and last year and uh then I'll give
you my answer and that answer would be
are you kidding me I know no way
um but you know Zach do the Jets know
what they have in Zach Wilson yeah
definitely they definitely know it's not
much they have
them that do overall and they have them
under contracts and listen don't don't
underestimate the little the Hard Knocks
saccharin that they can sprinkle on
things that team makes everybody look
like the greatest story you've ever seen
and Zach Wilson has had a great summer
he's trying hard and he's jovial and
he's listening to Rogers he still steps
in and throws a terrible interception to
Matt Milano last it was just awful he's
not gonna be the guy but he can hand off
and man they can run and play some d-dan
and if they get to I don't know ten and
seven maybe they squeak in and then pray
Rogers swims back next year but they
definitely know what they have give me
the storyline good or bad that will
continue so after week one's results
take the Jets out of this but the the
week one
question uh good or bad uh that that
persists the entire season it wasn't an
uh you know an aberration
well I like to say that week one in the
NFL is a liar it is it is a pathological
liar weird bizarre things happen in week
one that are completely unique to week
twos through 18. last year you remember
the Bears beat the Niners week one the
year before that the Jameis Winston
Saints destroyed the Aaron Rodgers
Packers so a lot of these things these
familiar brands that we've all trusted
in they'll bounce back the Bengals are
not going to be terrible the Steelers
aren't the bills aren't the one that I'm
worried about is the Bears and I'm
really worried about the Bears and
Fields at Al because I'm starting to see
this disgusting cycle Dan for Justin
fields and you start to see it where the
people online and the fans will say oh
the old line this and the coordinator
that and that stuff carries weight for a
while but when you're in year three and
you've drafted online and you spent
money and you drafted the receiver it's
it's like the parent Dan who like the
the quarterback is their kid and they're
you know the kids struggling in sports
and this ah the coach isn't teaching
them right and the kid can't get the
math test we gotta get new teachers
after a while your kid is stupid or not
athletic I'm sorry but we can only say
that for so long a kid's 17. Nick Saba's
not calling my friend that's what I'm
worried about with fields
I don't know why there was such great
lofty expectations for the Bears that's
asinine I got it I didn't get you know I
Paulie is a Bears fan I go why were your
expectations so high
and he goes I I don't know maybe Paulie
was high and that's why he had high
expectations like what are you doing I
mean it's still the Bears at the end of
the day and you know that receivers go
there to die Justin Fields is maybe who
we think he is that's just a nice
curiosity
he the offense seems to be
every once in
so nine yards and move the chains and
everybody loses their minds he never
seems to throw the timing passes damn
they're the number one pick in the draft
they held it they had their keys to the
party and they traded it for a Panthers
receiver who they threw to three times
in the first game of the season that was
field 28th start that was Jordan Love's
third start it was a nightmare I'm
listen you guys know Holly knows like
there have been five or six days in my
life that have been disappointing as a
chicagoan we already named one the Steve
Bartman game
Scottie Pippen refusing to enter the
game when Phil Jackson threw up a play
for Tony cucoach the second half of the
Rex crowsman Super Bowl my prom and the
game on Sunday against the Packers it's
just all terrible disappointments Bears
don't score we don't score our prom yeah
exactly right
that's good yeah imagine how your date
probably tells that story too I mean she
probably had a bad night too terrible
then the whole thing was that was at the
O'Hare Hyatt
O'Hare hotel we go we went as platonic
friends we go to some House at the End
there's four other couples the second we
finish dinner they go to four separate
rooms and my thumb platonic friend and I
are playing Uno on prom night I swear to
God you can't make it up
oh you are the Bears of prom dates we
really are
one of those cards I take it and slapped
down I had terrible cards the worst
good to talk to you thank you again Kyle
thanks for having me I love you guys
that's Kyle brand co-host of NFL
Networks good morning football got a lot
of energy a lot of energy there and torn
Achilles Survivor